una de las peores tragedias de
contrabando marítimo en California así
calificó el jefe de bomberos al
naufragio de dos embarcaciones pesqueras
utilizadas para trasladar migrantes y
que dejaron ocho personas muertas los
rescatistas no pudieron identificar la
procedencia de las víctimas pero
aseguraron que se trata de adultos esto
es parte de un esfuerzo de una
organización criminal transnacional para
contrabandear personas a los Estados
Unidos estas personas a menudo son
objeto de trata laboral y sexual cuando
llegan
el jefe de salvavidas de San Diego
agregó que alrededor de 23 personas iban
en los botes los cuales volcaron cerca
de la orilla como consecuencia de las
dificultades climáticas que experimenta
la región
los sobrevivientes se dieron a la fuga
según los funcionarios costeros en las
playas de San Diego cercanas a las del
estado mexicano de Tijuana los
accidentes son materia frecuente
tendría que buscar los números exactos
pero hemos tenido un par de cientos de
eventos este año fiscal está en
consonancia con los últimos años
Fiscales por lo general este año hubo
alrededor de 300 eventos marítimos pero
Eso incluye nadadores pangas y
embarcaciones de recreo
en San Diego suceden diversas accidentes
de personas que buscan llegar a Estados
Unidos tanto nadando como en botes
precarios pero este episodio es de los
más graves que se han registrado